Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. I can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Julia. But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute. What kind of espresso drinks does Julia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。要想收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告版本、系列节目的抢先收听，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。我总是拼不对。所以你只能用一个假名字，比如你咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。但你用得越多，就越觉得自己像是进了证人保护计划。等等。朱莉娅到底喜欢什么浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做浓缩咖啡。
Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. What is it but nightfall? No, no, not night but death. Was it needless death after all? For England may keep faith for all that is done and said. We know their dream, enough to know they dreamed and are dead. And what if excess of love bewildered them till they died? I write it out in a verse. Macdonagh and McBride and Connolly and Pearce, now and in time to be, green is worn are changed changed utterly a terrible beauty
立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。除了黑夜，还能是什么？不，不，不是黑夜，而是死亡。这终究是一场无谓的死亡吗？因为无论人们做了什么、说了什么，英格兰或许仍会信守承诺。我们了解他们的梦想，足以知道他们曾有过梦想，如今却已死去。如果过度的爱让他们迷失，直到死去，又当如何？我将这一切写成诗句。麦克多纳、麦克布莱德、康诺利和皮尔斯，现在以及未来的岁月里，身着绿装已全然改变，彻底改变了一场可怕的美丽
is born so dominic those are the the closing lines of william butler yates's great poem easter 1916 written about the easter rising yeah which we began this series it seems a long time ago several centuries ago with um with the proclamation read by patrick pierce outside the gpo where we are currently sitting as we reach the fourth and final episode in our great suite through the history of ireland and its relations right and it's extraordinary to be doing this story, the Easter Rising, 1916. Surely the most discussed, celebrated moment in Irish history. It's extraordinary to be recording that in the GPO, in the building that was the epicentre of the drama.
诞生了。所以，多米尼克，这些就是威廉·巴特勒·叶芝伟大诗作《1916年复活节》的结尾诗行，这首诗是为复活节起义而写的。是的，我们在本系列节目开始时提到了它，感觉是很久以前的事了，几个世纪前，帕特里克·皮尔斯在总邮局（GPO）门外宣读了宣言，而我们现在正坐在那里。当我们迎来关于爱尔兰历史及其关系的宏大系列的第四集也是最后一集时，对，能讲述这个故事真是太不可思议了——复活节起义，1916年。这无疑是爱尔兰历史上被讨论最多、被庆祝最多的时刻。在总邮局录制节目，在作为这场戏剧中心舞台的建筑里录制，这感觉太不可思议了。
We're looking out over O'Connell Street, the buses, the trams. So if you do hear a bit of banging and crashing outside and sirens and whatnot, that's all part of the exciting Irish local colour. And we're back with the person who read that proclamation for us so brilliantly at the beginning of the first episode, Paul Rouse, Professor of History at University College Dublin. So, Paul, the stage is set and, you know, off you go. I mean, this is your story.
我们正俯瞰着奥康奈尔街、公共汽车和有轨电车。所以，如果你听到外面有一些敲打声、碰撞声、警笛声之类的杂音，那都是令人兴奋的爱尔兰本土风情的一部分。我们请回了在第一集开头为我们极其精彩地宣读那份宣言的人，保罗·罗斯，都柏林大学学院的历史学教授。所以，保罗，舞台已经搭好了，你知道的，请开始吧。我的意思是，这是你的故事。
I don't think you want two British people to be telling the story of the Easter Rising, do you, or do you? Well, I think it is an extraordinary story. It's a British story and an Irish story. And Tommy Redd from WB8s, it's a story of poet and poets and their poetry and its impact. It's a story of poverty from another strand with James Connolly. It's a story of poverty from another strand with James Connolly. It's a story of language and education with Patrick Pearce.
我想你不会希望两个英国人来讲述复活节起义的故事吧，还是说你希望？嗯，我认为这是一个非凡的故事。这是一个英国的故事，也是一个爱尔兰的故事。正如威廉·巴特勒·叶芝笔下的汤姆·雷德所言，这是一个关于诗人和诗歌及其影响力的故事。与詹姆斯·康诺利有关的则是另一个维度的关于贫困的故事。与詹姆斯·康诺利有关的则是另一个维度的关于贫困的故事。与帕特里克·皮尔斯有关的则是关于语言和教育的故事。
And it's a story of those ardent revolutionaries who were there, who all walked in right under where we stand here at the GPO just before noon on Easter Monday, 1916, 24th of April, and declared an Irish Republic in this building. And you read the bit about Pearson McDonagh. I come to the start of that poem though, which Yeats wrote several months after the rising. He's ambiguous in how he views the rising, but he didn't publish it in 1920,
这是一个关于那些坚定革命者的故事，他们在1916年4月24日星期一复活节正午之前，齐聚并走进了我们现在所在的这座总邮局（GPO）下方，并在大楼里宣告了一个爱尔兰共和国。你刚才读了关于皮尔斯和麦克多纳的那部分。不过，我还是想回到这首诗的开头，这是叶芝在起义几个月后写的。他对起义的看法是复杂的，但他直到1920年才发表这首诗，
which is really interesting. He held on to it because the world was changed and he says changed utterly, but it was changing with a rapidity after 1916, which emphasizes just what a pivotal moment in Irish history it is, and by extension in the history of the United Kingdom. But he opened that poem, Easter 1916, by saying, I have met them at close of day, coming with vivid faces. And for those people who read deeply in Irish history, they'll know that Vivid Faces is a brilliant book written by Professor Roy Foster, who was just an outstanding historian in Oxford for very many years. And that idea that I met them at close of day, these were people that
这真的很有趣。他一直把它留着，因为世界已经变了，他说“彻底改变了”，但在1916年之后，这种改变是以惊人的速度进行的，这凸显了这是爱尔兰历史上多么关键的一个时刻，进而也是联合王国历史上的一个关键时刻。但他开篇写下《1916年复活节》时说：“我在日暮时分遇见他们，带着生动的面孔走来。”对于那些深入研读爱尔兰历史的人来说，他们会知道《生动的面孔》是一本杰出的书，由罗伊·福斯特教授撰写，他在牛津大学担任了多年极其杰出的历史学家。而那种“我在日暮时分遇见他们”的想法，这些人是叶芝所熟知的，也是都柏林人所熟知的，是全城各地的人们所熟知的。你必须记住，都柏林曾是一座小城市。都柏林过去常常、而且有时现在依然感觉像一个乡村小镇，因为它的中心是如此之小。你今天走在这座城市的街道上，依然无法不遇到你认识的人，或者在不同的地方偶遇他们。
were known to Yeats and known to Dubliners, known to people all around the place. And you must remember Dublin was a small city. Dublin felt and still sometimes feels like a country town because its centre is so small. You can't walk the streets of this city still without meeting someone who you know or running into them in different places.
爱尔兰是个小国家。所以即使是搬到这里的人也会被人熟知，这里有各种联系和关系网，同时也有家族、学校和在这座城市重塑的本土忠诚。它们贯穿了整个时期。那么，这些人到底是谁呢？叶芝所歌颂的、在1916年复活节迈出这命运一步的人究竟是谁？他们是在美国和英国的大饥荒后建立的。他们有来自美国的枪支源源不断地运进来，有资金源源不断地流进来。但事实是，自1867年以来，他们什么革命都没有做过。他们曾试图进入政坛，成为组织的一部分，但他们不能算是成功的。事实上，他们被嘲笑为一群老家伙，根本没干出什么大事。
And Ireland is a small country. So even people who move up to the place are known and there are connections and there are, it's networks of associations, but also a family and of schooling and of local loyalties remade in this city. And they're all across this period. So who are these people then? Who are the people who Yates is eulogizing and who take this fateful step in Easter in 1916? founded after the famine in America and in England. They had flows of guns, flows of money coming from America. But the truth of it is, they had done nothing about revolution since 1867. They had sought to enter into politics and to be part of organization, but they could not be considered to be successful. Indeed, they were mocked as a group of old people who really didn't do a whole pile.
如果你看看他们中的一员——该组织在1906、1907年进行了重组。是新一代人接管了爱尔兰共和兄弟会（IRB），其中一个人，为了让你了解
And if you look at one of their number, it was reconstituted in 1906, 1907. And it was a new generation took over the IRB and one of them, and to give you an idea
他们是什么样的人，其中一位就是丹尼斯·麦卡洛（Dennis McCullough）。丹尼斯·麦卡洛被带到贝尔法斯特的一家酒吧，并宣誓加入爱尔兰共和兄弟会。他是被父亲带去那家酒吧的。
of what they were like, one of them is Dennis McCullough. Dennis McCullough was brought into a pub in Belfast and sworn into the IRB. He was brought to the pub by his father.
所以这是一个某种秘密组织。秘密组织。有点像芬尼亚共济会。完全正确。他们致力于由他的父亲带去酒吧。所以这是一个某种秘密组织。有点像芬尼亚共济会。完全正确。他们致力于
So it's a kind of secret organisation. Secret organisation. It's kind of like Finian Freemasons. That's exactly it. And they're dedicated to the pub by his father. So it's a kind of secret organisation. It's kind of like a Fenian Freemasons. That's exactly it. And they're dedicated to the overthrow of British rule in Ireland. And by violent
推翻英国对爱尔兰的统治。显然是通过暴力
means apparently. And McCullough in this pub was disgusted by what he saw. He saw a whole load of windbags who had no interest in doing anything. So he shipped them out one after the next, including his own father. So when his own generation came in, the one person from the older generation who was central to that was Tom Clark. So Tom Clark had
手段。麦卡洛在这家酒吧里对所见所闻感到厌恶。他看到了一大堆夸夸其谈、对做事毫无兴趣的人。于是他一个接一个地把他们踢了出去，包括他自己的父亲。所以当他自己那一代人掌权时，老一辈中对核心事务起决定作用的人就是汤姆·克拉克（Tom Clark）。汤姆·克拉克曾
been involved in a dynamiting campaign in the 1880s in England, was arrested, spent a lot of time in English prisons, came out around 1900, went to America for a few years, but in 1906 was living around the corner from here where he ran a tobaccoist. And that tobaccoist shop became a hub of revolution. People coming in and out of it, passing notes. He's reorganizing the Irish Republican Brotherhood, who are ready to go. And at the core of this revolution is the Irish Republican Brotherhood, who, it was Clark who held a meeting just after the outbreak of the Great War in September 1914, who said, we will strike before this war ends.
参与了1980年代在英国的炸弹袭击活动，被捕后在英国监狱里度过了很长时间，1900年前后出狱，在美国呆了几年，但在1906年时，他就住在离这里转角不远的地方，在那里经营一家烟草店。那家烟草店成了革命的中心。人们进进出出，传递便条。他正在重组爱尔兰共和兄弟会，他们已经准备就绪。而这场革命的核心就是爱尔兰共和兄弟会，正是克拉克在1914年9月第一次世界大战爆发后不久举行了一次会议，说道：“我们将在这次战争结束前发动打击。”
He was disgusted that there had been no rebellion during the Boer War, and he was determined not to miss this chance. So Clark set on revolution. And later, in early 1915, set up a small military council to develop the plans. So there at the core of everything that happens is the Irish Republican Brotherhood. The second group who are involved are a group of socialists, essentially the Irish Citizen Army, headed by James Connolly. Connolly was born in Scotland, born in Edinburgh, to Irish emigrant parents who had come to Ireland as a labour organiser
他对布尔战争期间没有爆发起义感到厌恶，并决心不再错过这个机会。于是克拉克坚定了革命的决心。后来，在1915年初，他成立了一个小型军事委员会来制定计划。因此，发生的一切的核心都是爱尔兰共和兄弟会。第二组参与者是一群社会主义者，主要是由詹姆斯·康诺利（James Connolly）领导的爱尔兰公民军（Irish Citizen Army）。康诺利出生于苏格兰爱丁堡，父母是爱尔兰移民，他作为一名劳工组织者来到爱尔兰，
and had been involved in the 1913 lockout, which was a really famous trade union conflict with businesses in Dublin, which was a seminal moment again in Irish labour politics. And it was a vivid illustration of the poverty of Dublin and And the poverty of Dublin, there's all this nonsense spoken about Dublin as a second city of empire, of the second city of empire. What does that even mean? What does it mean to be the second city of empire? And it was the style of Birmingham as well, by the way,
曾参与1913年的工人大罢工。这是一场都柏林企业与工会之间非常著名的冲突，也是爱尔兰劳工政治中又一个具有开创性的时刻。这是都柏林贫困状况的生动写照，有关都柏林的贫困，人们说了很多废话，把它吹捧为帝国的第二大城市，帝国的第二大城市。这到底是什么意思？成为帝国的第二大城市意味着什么？顺便说一句，这也是伯明翰的风格，
and Calcutta and Edinburgh. So it was one of those titles. But what Dublin did was, was a deeply divided society where you had a crust of people with a lot of money. In the beginning. There's a rising middle class, but on the bottom, there are people who are in the most appalling circumstances living around the place. So you get 25,000 families living in one room accommodation.
还有加尔各答和爱丁堡。所以这是那种虚名之一。但都柏林实际是一个深深分裂的社会，有一小群人拥有巨额财富。起初。新兴的中产阶级正在崛起，但在底层，人们生活在最骇人听闻的糟糕环境中。因此，你会发现有25,000个家庭挤在单间公寓里生活。
Many of those families even took in lodgers into their one room. They had no sanitation, no running water. There were often cattle and sheep, or cattle kept out the back of the houses for milk and so on. So this is a very poor, very poor city. And it was out of this city that labor agitation began in 1913. But the labor agitation happened at exactly the same time, of course, as the Ulster Volunteers had been founded by Carson. So James Connolly had a simple idea. We would protect our workers by setting up our own militia, the Irish Citizen Army, and they trained. And Connolly was disillusioned by 1915 with progress. The war had got in on him. He was himself a former British Army soldier, by the way,
许多这样的家庭甚至在他们唯一的房间里还要招揽房客。他们没有卫生设施，没有自来水。房子后面往往还养着牛、羊，或者为了牛奶等目的把牛养在后院。所以这是一个非常贫穷、非常贫穷的城市。正是在这座城市里，劳工运动于1913年爆发了。但劳工运动爆发的同时，卡森（Carson）也创立了阿尔斯特志愿者军（Ulster Volunteers）。因此，詹姆斯·康诺利有了一个简单的想法。我们要通过建立自己的民兵组织——爱尔兰公民军来保护我们的工人，他们进行了训练。到了1915年，康诺利对进展感到幻灭。战争已经波及到他，顺便说一句，他本人曾是一名英国陆军士兵，
but he set on revolution too. The volunteers knew he was set on revolution, so they pulled him into his military council. So that's the second group of people. And just before you move on to the next groups, that shows, doesn't it, just how much Irish politics has been radicalized and I suppose paramilitarized by the experience of 1912 to 14. It is impossible to understand the 1916 rising without looking at the militarization of Irish society begun by Edward Carson and the Ulster Volunteer Force and their foundation, added to by the gun running at Larne, where the Ulster Volunteer Force brought in German and other guns with which to say that they will resist home rule at any cost in Ulster, radicalized also by the uncertain loyalty of the British
但他同样决心发动革命。志愿者们知道他决心已定，于是把他拉进了他们的军事委员会。这就是第二批人。在你转向下一批人之前，这表明了，不是吗？爱尔兰政治在1912至1914年经历的洗礼下，已经被极端化了，我想也被准军事化了。如果不审视爱尔兰社会的军事化进程——这一进程由爱德华·卡森（Edward Carson）和阿尔斯特志愿者部队（Ulster Volunteer Force）的发起而拉开序幕，并在拉恩（Larne）的走私枪支事件中得到加强（当时阿尔斯特志愿者部队运进了德国和其他国家的枪支，以此表明他们将在阿尔斯特不惜一切代价抵抗地方自治），同时又被英国
army in Ireland through its Curragh mutiny, essentially says we will not dispossess the Ulster volunteer force of those guns which they have brought in. I mean, how extraordinary is it that the British army could not be relied on to do the will of the British government? What a statement of the state of British politics that that is. But the Irish volunteers under Eoin MacNeill, a professor of medieval history
军队在爱尔兰动摇不定的忠诚度（通过其长官兵变，实质上表明我们不会解除阿尔斯特志愿者部队走私进来的枪支）所极端化——就根本无法理解1916年的起义。我的意思是，英国军队竟然不可信赖去执行英国政府的意志，这有多么不可思议？这简直是对英国政治现状的一份极其真实的宣言。当时的爱尔兰志愿者由欧文·麦克尼尔（Eoin MacNeill）领导，他当时是都柏林大学学院的中世纪历史
and early Irish history at University College Dublin at the time, and a complete and utter rebuttal to the idea that academics are useless, founded the Irish volunteer force after writing an article
和早期爱尔兰历史教授，他的存在彻底驳斥了“学者无用”的观点，他在写了一篇
called The North Began. And they too began to run in guns through 1914. And you get this split then after the war when John Redmond asked those volunteers to join the British army and fight for the empire, thereby guaranteeing home rule of the volunteers. I'll come back to explain that split more fully when we talk about more people in it. But what it meant was that there was a standing army of 10 to 15 000 people who were in ireland the militia who were there to be tweaked towards the idea of revolution but that militarization of of ireland you're right like dominic it's fundamental to the context in which there are guns and people out parading in Dublin. So the other groups that are involved.
名为《北方开始了》的文章后，创立了爱尔兰志愿者部队。他们在1914年也开始走私枪支。然后，在战争爆发后，当约翰·雷德蒙（John Redmond）要求这些志愿者加入英国军队并为帝国战斗，从而保证地方自治时，就出现了这种分裂。当我谈到更多相关人员时，我会回过头来更充分地解释这种分裂。但这意味着，爱尔兰当时存在一支1万到1.5万人的常备军——即民兵，他们随时准备被引导向革命的思想，但爱尔兰的这种军事化，正如你所说的那样，多米尼克，它是都柏林街头有枪支和游行人群这一背景的基础。所以，还有其他参与进来的群体。
So we've got the IRB, the Irish Republican Brotherhood, the Irish Citizens Army. And there are other groups as well. So there are poets, there are educators. There are more ideas than groups. So you've got a group of groups of kind of Catholic intellectuals, people like Thomas McDonagh. Again, these people are brilliantly described in vivid faces and their ideas are all over the place and they're part of a a kind of an irish ireland movement which is all around the idea that you know ireland should have its own culture it's an awakening of ideas using modern ideas and you know the way there was
因此，我们有了IRB（爱尔兰共和兄弟会）、爱尔兰公民军。还有其他一些群体。所以有诗人，有教育家。这里的思想比团体还要多。所以你有一群天主教知识分子，比如托马斯·麦克多纳（Thomas McDonagh）。同样，这些人被《生动的面孔》一书进行了精彩的描述，他们的思想无处不在，他们是一个被称为“爱尔兰的爱尔兰”运动的一部分，这一运动的核心理念是爱尔兰应该拥有自己的文化，这是一场运用现代思想的观念觉醒，你知道那种感觉吗？
british press would tell a kind of biggles type stories for the late 19th And you know the way there was British press would tell a kind of Biggles type stories for the late 19th century. You know that idea of magazines being put out. There were Irish versions of those stories where the heroes of 1798
英国媒体在19世纪后期会讲述类似“比格斯”（Biggles）风格的故事。你知道那种杂志出版的理念吗？当时有这些故事的爱尔兰版本，其中1798年、
and of 1848 and of 1867 were recast. Because one of the things that struck me reading about the Easter Rising is that a lot of the Irish nationalist organisations are definitely drawing on British models. of the things that struck me reading about the easter rising is that a lot of the the irish
1848年和1867年的英雄们被重新塑造。因为在阅读关于复活节起义的资料时，让我印象深刻的一点是，许多爱尔兰民族主义组织绝对是在借鉴英国的模式。阅读关于复活节起义的资料时，让我印象深刻的一点是，许多爱尔兰
nationalist organizations are definitely drawing on british models even the irish volunteers are they're kind of doing drill like the british army do their officers are mimicking the style of british officers yeah i mean so and that whole cult of kind of manliness we did an episode on king solomon's minds just a few weeks ago this has been kind of gyliness. We did an episode on King Solomon's Mines just a few weeks ago. This has been kind of gaelicised, I suppose you would say. Yeah, they gaelicised it by turning it on its head. So you have the English model of sport in Ireland. You have rugby and soccer and cricket and formed in modern clubs around Ireland, but they fly the Union Jack. They have the Lord Lieutenant as their patron. So in the middle of the 1880s,
民族主义组织绝对是在借鉴英国的模式，甚至连爱尔兰志愿者也是如此——他们的训练方式有点像英国陆军，他们的军官在模仿英国军官的风格。是的，我的意思是，还有那种对男子气概的崇拜——我们在几周前刚刚做过一期关于《所罗门王的宝藏》的节目——这已经被赋予了某种盖尔化色彩，我想你会这么说。是的，他们通过将其颠覆来进行盖尔化。所以在爱尔兰，你拥有英国的体育模式。你有橄榄球、足球和板球，它们在爱尔兰各地围绕现代俱乐部建立起来，但它们悬挂着米字旗。它们由总督担任赞助人。所以在1880年代中期，
a group of Irish nationalists, but people who were sports lovers, founded the Gaelic Athletic Association and resurrected the game of hurling, made a game which they called Gaelic football, took control of athletics and said, right, you choose English laws for sport or Irish laws for sport.
一群爱尔兰民族主义者，同时也是体育爱好者，创立了盖尔运动协会（GAA），复兴了 hurling（爱尔兰式曲棍球）运动，创造了一种他们称之为“盖尔式足球”的运动，接管了田径运动，并说：“好了，你们可以为体育选择英国法律，也可以为体育选择爱尔兰法律。”
Now, of course, the reality of people's lives are that people don't necessarily live like that. They want a little bit of this and a little bit of everything really. And, but that's there. Those ideas are there in the background. It's English popular culture is everywhere in Ireland in the late 19th and early 20th century. There's a sort of Boy Scout aspect to this, isn't there? Yeah.
当然，现实生活中人们并不一定非得那样生活。人们实际上希望有一点这个，有一点每样东西。但它确实存在。这些想法在背景中若隐若现。19世纪末和20世纪初，英国流行文化在爱尔兰无处不在。这里面有一种类似童子军的成分，不是吗？是的。
So Nafina Aaron is a remaking of the English Scout movement, except soaked in the history of Irish republicanism and the idea of Irish separatism. And loads of those guys walk into this building with Pierce in 1916. And that really, really matters to the idea of a creation. And this is the last thing, this idea, this last group of people who are influenced
因此，娜菲娜·埃伦（Na Fianna Éireann）就是对英国童子军运动的重新演绎，只不过浸透了爱尔兰共和主义的历史和爱尔兰分裂主义的思想。1916年，许多这样的小伙子跟着皮尔斯走进了这座建筑。这对塑造这种思想来说非常、非常重要。而这正是最后一点，最后一群人，他们受到
by the idea of Ireland, by this notion. And there's a school not far from here, St. Andrew's National School. And the roll book for Easter week 1916 has no students in it because it says closed for the poet's revolution. And that tells you something. So where does poetry come into the revolution? I think poetry comes in, in three different ways. The first of it is this creation of the idea, the alternative to the British empire. And this idea, this world of ideas that there is an ancient Ireland
爱尔兰观念、这种概念的影响。离这里不远有一所学校，圣安德鲁国立学校。1916年复活节那一周的花名册上没有一个学生，因为上面写着：“为诗人的革命而关闭。”这说明了一些问题。那么，诗歌是如何融入这场革命的呢？我认为诗歌以三种不同的方式融入其中。首先是理念的创造，即英国帝国的替代方案。这种思想，这种思想世界——即通过历史重塑一个古老的爱尔兰，
remade through its history, that there is mythology through Cú Chulainn and Nafina, which can be put there and this, our antiquity, we were there before the British Empire was,
通过库胡林（Cú Chulainn）和娜菲娜（Na Fianna）建立神话，这些可以被置于此处，我们的古老历史，我们在英国帝国之前就存在了，
we were there before they even, before the Anglo-Saxons even pitched up. Yeah, we were here and we'll survive them. Yeah. We'll be fine. We will go back to our ways.
在盎格鲁-撒克逊人到来之前我们就已经存在了。是的，我们一直在这里，而且我们会比他们活得更久。是的。我们会没事的。我们会回到我们自己的生活方式中去。
So that idea is there. So poetry matters for that. It helped create that. It matters too because there were poets who fought and died in the rising or were executed after the rising. Pierce wrote poetry. McDonagh was a really well-regarded poet. James Connolly wrote poetry and plays and so on. This was a revolution of words and revolutionaries who used words
所以这种想法是存在的。因此，诗歌对此至关重要。它有助于创造这种思想。它也很重要，因为有诗人在起义中战斗并牺牲，或者在起义后被处决。皮尔斯写过诗。麦克多纳是一位备受推崇的诗人。詹姆斯·康诺利写过诗歌和戏剧等等。这是一场言语的革命，革命者们
all the time. And the third may it matters is the words of Yeats afterwards and the amount and the words that were written about it and how they told a very particular story of the revolution. And that can be seen in the accounts from the time and afterwards. So again, reading about this
时刻都在使用言语。第三个重要之处在于叶芝事后的诗句，以及关于它的文字写作，以及它们如何讲述了一个非常特定的革命故事。这可以从当时和后来的记载中看出。所以再次强调，阅读这些
again and again, scholars make this point. So Peter Hart described the entire Easter Rising as a unique example of insurrectionally abstract art, which I thought was kind of brilliant. What does he mean by that? My favourite book on the idea of this, and I commend it to everybody, it was recommended to me when I took a course in the Irish Revolution in 1989 by Professor Michael Athan, called The Imagination of an Insurrection, written by an American philosopher called William Erwin Thompson. It is just the most magnificent exploration of the relationship between poetry and revolution and the human condition and how those three things are not, you know,
资料时，学者们反复提出这一观点。彼得·哈特（Peter Hart）将整个复活节起义描述为“绝无仅有的抽象艺术暴动”的范例，我觉得这真是太精彩了。他这是什么意思？我最喜欢的一本探讨这个想法的书——我向所有人强烈推荐它，这是我在1989年修读爱尔兰革命课程时，由迈克尔·阿坦（Michael Athan）教授向我推荐的，书名叫《一次起义的想象力》，由一位名叫威廉·欧文·汤普森（William Erwin Thompson）的美国哲学家所写。它绝对是对诗歌、革命与人类境况之间关系最宏伟的探索，以及这三者如何不是……你知道的，
they're all related and all intertwined. And there is a thing, there is a thing where people have taken selected writings from some of the people, notably Patrick Pearce from The Rising, and see it only as bloodlust. And they decontextualize it from the idea of war in Europe at the time and the stuff that was being written
它们是息息相关、交织在一起的。有一种观点认为，人们从起义的某些人（特别是帕特里克·皮尔斯）那里摘录了部分作品，并将其仅仅视为嗜血。他们将这些作品与当时欧洲战争的背景脱节，也与第一次世界大战诗人们所写的内容脱节。
by the poets of the Great War and what they saw. And it was as if there was a death wish from some people that they saw it And it was as if there was a death wish from some people that they saw it as theater, that they didn't understand that these were somehow woolly people who did not understand what war was. And that is entirely wrong. In my view, they went and planned this for a long time. You may argue that the plans turn out to be terrible and impossible and that it did indeed become bloody protest rather than coup d'etat.
就好像有些人有一种求死的心愿，他们把这看作是一场戏剧，他们不明白这些人其实是些糊涂蛋，根本不懂战争是什么。这种看法完全是错误的。在我看来，他们去策划了这件事，而且策划了很长时间。你可能会辩称，这些计划结果证明是糟糕的、不切实际的，它确实演变成了一场血腥的抗议，而不是一场政变。
You may argue that, but they fought, they struggled for a long time to plan for it. But this is the idea that Patrick Pearce in particular is associated with it, that they know that the revolution is going to be wiped out, that they will probably be killed. And so that they are kind of offering themselves up, the phrase is, as a blood sacrifice, modelled on the sacrifice of Christ on the cross. Yeah, it's kind of like the fact that it was Easter as well, and that it's kind of insurrection as resurrection, and that it's poetry and prayer, and it's all rubbed in together. But where I think that breaks down is the extent to which
你或许可以这么说，但他们为策划此事进行过长期、艰难的抗争。这就是帕特里克·皮尔斯（Patrick Pearce）所特有的那种思想，他们知道这场革命将被消灭，他们很可能会被杀害。因此，他们是将自己作为“血祭”奉献出来，其模式是以基督在十字架上的牺牲为原型的。是的，这就有点像它恰好发生在复活节，而且这种起义就像是复活一样，这是诗歌与祈祷的结合，所有这些都交织在了一起。但我认为这种说法站不住脚的地方在于，
they sought to arm themselves from Germany. They sought to go, why did Pierce go on speaking tours of America? Why did they try and raise money? Why did they import so many guns? Why did they spend
他们试图从德国获取武器的程度。他们试图去探讨——为什么皮尔斯要去美国进行巡回演讲？为什么他们试图筹集资金？为什么他们进口了这么多的枪支？为什么他们花费了
more than a year planning? So they're planning from what point? From the moment the war breaks out or from a few months? They're talking about it from the moment, they decide the moment the war breaks out, but the military council really gets going in the spring of 1915. So home rule has been passed, but it's been constantly pushed back, delayed. And is that because, is the reason they want to do an uprising because they think
一年多的时间来做计划？那么他们是从什么时候开始计划的呢？是从战争爆发的那一刻起，还是从几个月前？他们从那一刻起就开始谈论了，他们决定在战争爆发时动手，但军事委员会真正开始运作是在1915年春季。因此，地方自治法案已经通过，但它不断被推迟、延期。这是因为，他们之所以想要发动起义，是因为他们认为
actually the British will always find a way not to give us home rule or because they think home rule is just nowhere near enough. We want to push for more. So the view is that home rule is not enough, that because of the limitations to do with finance and on defence, that really it's anemic and it doesn't amount to anything approaching independence. Number one. Number two, the home rule was on the statute books had been passed signed off by the king but it was now clear that there was going to be exclusion for at least six counties for a period of time and clearly indefinitely because a tory government would come back in and you know things will be changed and things will be moved on yeah and there was that old adage of irish republicanism
实际上英国人总能找到不给我们地方自治的办法，还是因为他们认为地方自治远远不够？我们想要争取更多。所以当时的观点是，地方自治是不够的，由于在财政和国防方面的限制，它实际上苍白无力，根本谈不上接近独立。这是第一点。第二点，地方自治法案虽然已经列入法典，并由国王签署通过，但现在很明显，至少有六个郡将在一段时间内被排除在外，而且显然是无限期地排除在外，因为保守党政府将会重新掌权，你知道的，事情会发生变化，事情会推陈出新。是的。爱尔兰共和主义还有一个老生常谈的观点，
which ties in with the idea of Ireland being dangerous because of its links with France and Spain. But this is it recast in a different way. The gallant allies in Europe, we can use these people to get ourselves the guns that we need. We can't get enough through America, but we can use the Germans to help us be freed. And that old adage of England's difficulty being being ireland's opportunity it's such a cliche but it's a cliche for a reason but why are the british not aware of what's going on i mean because if all these guns are being collected and poets are writing manifestos and yet it seems to take the british completely by surprise john dylan makes a speech
这与爱尔兰因为与法国和西班牙的联系而显得危险的看法相呼应。但这是以另一种方式重新塑造的。欧洲的英勇盟友，我们可以利用这些人来获取我们所需的枪支。我们无法通过美国获得足够的枪支，但我们可以利用德国人来帮助我们获得自由。老话说得好，“英国的困难就是爱尔兰的机遇”，这虽然是个老生常谈的陈词滥调，但陈词滥调之所以存在是有原因的。可为什么英国人却没有意识到正在发生的事情呢？我的意思是，如果所有这些枪支都被收集起来，诗人们在撰写宣言，然而这一切似乎让英国人感到完全措手不及。约翰·狄龙（John Dylan）在
in the spring of 1915 in scotland so john dylan is the just sorry i should explain that yeah so john dylan so back in in the spring of 1915 john dylan who's john redmond's number two in the irish parliamentary party is making a speech in scotland and, listen, there's a lot of talk at the moment about what's going to be arising in Ireland in the next while. He says, they're not going to do that. Like Michael Fish with the report of the hurricane. It's not going to come. But they know people are talking about it, Patrick Pearson and whatnot, but they think these are just, you know, it's like students in the pub talking about revolution.
1915年春季在苏格兰发表了一场演讲——所以约翰·狄龙就是……抱歉，我应该解释一下——是的，所以约翰·狄龙，在1915年春季，作为约翰·雷德蒙在爱尔兰议会党内的二号人物，在苏格兰发表了一场演讲，说道：“听着，现在有很多关于爱尔兰近期将爆发起义的谈论。”他说：“他们不会那样做的。”就像迈克尔·菲什（Michael Fish）播报飓风消息时那样。它不会来的。但他们知道人们在谈论它，帕特里克·皮尔斯之流，但他们认为这些不过是，你知道的，就像酒吧里的学生在谈论革命一样。
I mean, this will never happen. Is that basically a condescending attitude almost? It is, but it's understandable in very many respects, and not least because of the militarization that we spoke about. Because these Irish volunteers are actually up and down parading and have been for a couple of years. They're out on the streets. Right. years. They're out on the streets. And it's a familiar thing to see militias of men in military formation marching up and down the streets and being called and going on manoeuvres. So it's easy to understand and to convince yourself that it's going to be fine. Another reason, of course,
我的意思是，这永远不会发生。这基本上是一种居高临下的态度吗？是的，但在很多方面是可以理解的，尤其是考虑到我们刚才谈到的军事化。因为这些爱尔兰志愿者实际上一直在大街上列队游行，而且已经持续了好几年了。他们就在街上。对。几年。他们就在街上。看着身着军装的民兵列队在大街上行进、被点名并进行演习，已经成了一种司空见惯的景象。所以很容易理解并说服自己一切都会好起来的。当然，另一个原因
is that Redmond, John Redmond, was telling Augustine Burrell, the chief secretary for Ireland, and telling Dublin Castle and telling Wimberd, they're all new. Oh no, the worst thing you can do here is to move against these guys. Then you will cause revolution. Yeah, of course. I mean, that so often happens, right? Yes. So move against them, try to suppress them and you will give them a cause. Yeah. And essentially you can understand a lot of 1798 by understanding that approach. So it became British. It was the Commission of Inquiry after the Rising blamed Borel, Augustine Borel, and blamed Dublin Castle for their failures before the Rising. I think it's much more, it's not as clear as that. I think that's easy. It's an easy way to do it, but it doesn't hold water. So before we go to the break, Paul, and get into the actual story, the narrative, that the character who more than anybody else embodies the spirit of the Easter Rising, we've mentioned him a couple of times, but we've never really explained him, is this guy,
是雷德蒙，约翰·雷德蒙，当时在对爱尔兰首席秘书奥古斯丁·比雷尔（Augustine Birrell）说，在对都柏林城堡说，在对温伯德说，他们全都是新来的。“哦，不，你们在这里能做的最糟糕的事情就是对这些人采取行动。那样的话，你们才会真正引发革命。”是的，当然。我的意思是，这种情况经常发生，对吧？是的。所以对他们采取行动，试图镇压他们，反而会给他们提供一个借口。是的。从某种程度上说，理解1798年的历史很大程度上可以通过理解这种处理方式来实现。所以它最终成了英国的问题。起义后的调查委员会将责任归咎于比雷尔，即奥古斯丁·比雷尔，并指责都柏林城堡在起义前的失职。我认为事情远没有那么简单，并非如此一清二楚。我觉得这样说太容易了。这是一种偷懒的做法，根本经不起推敲。保罗，在我们休息一下并进入实际的故事、叙事之前，有这样一位人物——比起其他人，他更能体现复活节起义的精神——我们之前提到过他几次，但从未真正深入解释过他，这个人就是
Patrick Pearce. So he's actually been missing. When we did the Home Rule crisis and all that, his name never featured at all. I mean, I don't know. You said that everybody knew everybody in Dublin. But who is he? Is he a big figure? And how is it that he, more than anybody else, becomes the, you know, the walking embodiment of this kind of the spirit of this extraordinary year? In a revolution peopled everywhere by extraordinary characters, there is nobody quite like Patrick Pierce. He has his demonizers and he has his idolaters who have sought to position him in a certain way and to cast him in a certain light. And almost always they do disservice to the scale of the intellect that were there, the scale of achievements that were there outside the revolutionary sphere. So he was born into an English father who was... He was a Brummie, wasn't he?
帕特里克·皮尔斯。所以他实际上一直缺席。当我们讨论地方自治危机以及所有那些事情时，他的名字从未出现过。我的意思是，我不知道。你刚才说都柏林人人都认识。但他是谁？他是个大人物吗？为什么偏偏是他，比其他任何人都更能成为这个非凡年份的精神化身？在一个到处都是非凡人物的革命年代，没有人能与帕特里克·皮尔斯相比。他有将他妖魔化的人，也有将他顶礼膜拜的人，他们都试图以某种方式定位他，并将他置于某种光环之下。几乎在所有情况下，他们都贬低了他在革命领域之外的宏大智力成就和巨大成就。他出生于一个英国父亲家庭……他是个布鲁姆人（来自伯明翰），对吧？
Yeah, and Stolmason. And he went to university, studied English and Irish and French, qualified as a lawyer, but he was motivated most of all by Irish language revival and by involvement in the Gaelic League. He became editor of a newspaper
是的，来自斯托尔桥。他上了大学，主修英语、爱尔兰语和法语，获得了律师资格，但他最大的动力是爱尔兰语言的复兴以及对盖尔联盟的参与。他成为了一家名为
called On Clive Sullish, which was the most important Irish language publication there. And he sought always to expand the boundaries, but it was education which motivated him more than anything else.
《安克莱·苏利什》（An Claidheamh Soluis）的报纸的主编，这是当时最重要的爱尔兰语出版物。他一直试图拓展边界，但比其他任何事情更能激励他的，是教育。
He set up his own boys' school, St. Enda's, on the south side of Dublin and added a girls' school to it because he was an absolute believer in equality between men and women. So he set up St. Edith's, which only lasted a while. The education in St. Endes was Gaelic. The idea was that there should be education
他在都柏林南部创办了自己的男子学校——圣恩达学校（St. Enda's），并在其中增设了一所女子学校，因为他坚信男女平等。因此他创办了圣恩达学校，不过这所学校只维持了一段时间。圣恩达学校的教育是盖尔语的。其理念是应该通过
through bilingualism. And he went to Belgium and studied the methods that were used there, brought them back to Ireland and sought to kind of build a citizenship and an idea of intellectual journey, which was around this. Was he involved in politics? Yes, he began to be pulled into politics. He stood in favor of home rule. In 1912 and 1913, he believed in the idea of home rule. He didn't think it was enough, but he thought it was a decent thing to be going on with it was only later into 1914 that he really became radicalized onto the idea that there should be a revolution now some people say it's because his school was failing and that he needed money and his life was kind of unraveling on him and that he had painted himself into the corner where he needed to make a dramatic statement. I disagree with that. I think that's denying him his own agency. And he showed a clear pattern through his life of evolving his thought in a whole load of ways. I should say, by the way,
双语教育来进行。他曾去比利时研究那里的教学方法，将其带回爱尔兰，并试图围绕这一点建立公民意识和智力探索的理念。他参与政治了吗？是的，他开始被卷入政治。他支持地方自治。在1912年和1913年，他相信地方自治的理念。他虽然认为这还远远不够，但觉得这是一个可以接受的权宜之计。直到1914年晚些时候，他才真正激进化，确信现在就应该爆发革命。有些人说这是因为他的学校办不下去了，他需要钱，他的生活正走向崩溃，他把自己逼入了一个需要发表轰动性声明的死角。我不同意这种说法。我认为这是在剥夺他自主选择的权利。他在一生中表现出了清晰的模式，在许多方面不断演变自己的思想。顺便说一句，我应该顺便提一下，
in passing, if anyone wants to read a brilliant exploration of the education system in Britain and Ireland, read The Murder Machine, which is a book he wrote about how rote learning was destroying education at the time. And he called for creativity and innovation and a child-centered approach to education way, way, way ahead of his time. Anyway, he was on the military council, appointed to the military council of the IRB in 1915,
如果有人想阅读对英国和爱尔兰教育系统的精彩探索，可以读读《杀戮机器》（The Murder Machine），这是他写的一本书，讲述了死记硬背是如何摧毁当时的教育的。他呼吁创造力、创新以及以儿童为中心的教育方法，这在当时远远超越了那个时代。无论如何，他在1915年加入了军事委员会，被任命为爱尔兰共和兄弟会（IRB）军事委员会成员，
and he was then set on revolution. He was inspirational or driving the idea that there should be guns imported that there would be training and that ireland would rise and the date set for this rebellion was easter 1916 right i think at this point we should take a break and then when we come back you could take us through the events of Easter 1916. Chiara, it means smart in Italian. Too bad your barista can't spell it right. So you just give a fake name, your cafe name, Giulia.
从那时起他就铁心要闹革命了。他充满感召力，推动着必须进口枪支、必须进行训练、爱尔兰必须起义的理念，而这场叛乱的日期定在了1916年的复活节。好吧，我想我们此时应该休息一下，等我们回来时，你可以带我们了解1916年复活节的事件经过。基娅拉，在意大利语里意思是聪明。可惜你的咖啡师不会拼写它。所以你只能用一个假名字，比如你咖啡馆的名字，朱莉娅。
But the more you use it, the more it feels like you're in witness protection. Wait a minute, what kind of espresso drinks does Giulia like anyway? Is it too late to change your latte order? But with an espresso machine by KitchenAid, you wouldn't be thinking any of this because you could have just made your espresso at home. Shop now at KitchenAid.ca. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club.
但你用得越多，就越觉得自己像是进了证人保护计划。等等，朱莉娅到底喜欢什么浓缩咖啡饮料？现在改点拿铁还来得及吗？但如果你有一台 KitchenAid 的浓缩咖啡机，你就不会有这些烦恼了，因为你完全可以在家里自己做浓缩咖啡。立即前往 KitchenAid.ca 选购。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们联袂主持《娱乐的余烬》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论以及八卦爆料的首选。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。
If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. We are entering the final lap of this mighty Irish marathon. Paul Rouse, who has been doing a Herculean job. But Paul, the end is finally in sight for you. Take us through the story of Easter 1916.
如果你想享受无广告收听、独家加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们正在进入这场宏大的爱尔兰马拉松的最后一圈。保罗·罗斯（Paul Rouse）一直做着极其繁重的工作。不过，保罗，对你来说，终点线终于在望了。请带我们回顾1916年复活节的故事吧。
Sir Roger Casement, who would have been known across Britain and Ireland in the first two decades of the 20th century as the man who had investigated the imperial outrages in the Congo, who'd repeated it in the Amazon, who had then become a devotee of the idea of home rule and then became a gunrunner for the Irish volunteers. He went to Berlin at the beginning of the Great War and he sought to raise an army of Irish prisoners who'd been taken by the Germans to form a brigade to come over. He had sought also to convince the Germans to send 20,000 men or 15,000 or whatever they would give to the cause and land them in Limerick and they would march and take the land and failing that he wanted guns, he wanted rifles. Well, finally, before
罗杰·卡斯门特爵士（Sir Roger Casement）在20世纪的前二十年里，在整个英国和爱尔兰都广为人知，因为他曾调查过刚果的帝国暴行，并在亚马逊地区再次进行了调查，后来他成为了地方自治理念的信徒，接着又成为了爱尔兰志愿者的枪支走私者。第一次世界大战爆发时，他去了柏林，试图招募一支由德国俘虏的爱尔兰士兵组成的军队，组建一个旅渡海参战。他还曾试图说服德国人派遣2万或1.5万或其他他们愿意提供的军队支持这场运动，并在利默里克登陆，随后他们将进军并占领这片土地。如果做不到这一点，他希望得到枪支，他想要步枪。总之，最终在
Easter 1916, the Germans sent on a ship 20,000 guns and casement came by submarine to the south coast of Ireland. This was seen as what would make the revolution possible. There would be an uprising if there were guns, even if there weren't German soldiers themselves, but the volunteers would now have the weaponry with which to rise. Casement, everything went wrong. Casement ended up staggering onto the shore at Bannestrand in County Kerry, where he'd capsized on the boat and inflatable coming in. The ship on which the arms were being brought from Germany was intercepted and the captain of it scuttled it before it went into Queenstown in Cork. The question was, what would the rebels do who had said they were going to rise? The stats part of the story ended with Roger Casement being arrested and ultimately being imprisoned in the
1916年复活节前夕，德国人派了一艘船运送了2万支枪，而卡斯门特则乘潜艇来到了爱尔兰南海岸。这被视为使革命成为可能的关键。即使没有德国士兵本人，只要有了枪支，就会爆发起义，志愿者们现在将拥有起义所需的武器。然而对卡斯门特来说，一切都出了问题。卡斯门特最终踉踉跄跄地登上了凯里郡巴尼斯特兰德（Bannestrand）的海岸，他在乘小艇和充气艇上岸时翻船了。那艘运送武器的德国船只被拦截，船长在驶入科克郡昆斯敦（Queenstown）之前将其凿沉了。问题是，那些宣称要起义的叛军会怎么做呢？故事的这部分以罗杰·卡斯门特被捕并最终被监禁在
Tower of London. And after the rising, as we will see, he was hung in Pentonville prison in August 1916. By then, the whole situation in Ireland had been fundamentally changed. So he could at least say that he had played a part in the transformation of Ireland, though not in the manner in which he might have expected when he stepped off that submarine in April 1916. So that's all gone wrong. The question the rebels for pierce and his pals who have been planning this is do they go ahead anyway and they do go ahead anyway i mean it's the amazing thing isn't it they go ahead anyway and they can go ahead because what happened was immediately after the war began john redmond the leader of the irish parliamentary party called for the irish
伦敦塔。正如我们将会看到的，起义平息后，他在1916年8月被绞死在彭顿维尔监狱。到那时，爱尔兰的整体局势已经发生了根本性的变化。因此，他至少可以说是参与了爱尔兰的巨变，尽管这与他在1916年4月从那艘潜艇走出来时所预期的并不一样。所以这一切都搞砸了。皮尔斯和他的同伙们一直在筹划这场起义，他们面临的问题是：他们还要不要继续干？他们还是决定干下去。我的意思是，这真是太令人惊奇了不是吗？他们还是硬着头皮干了下去，而且他们能这样做，是因为在战争爆发后不久，爱尔兰议会党领袖约翰·雷德蒙呼吁爱尔兰
volunteers to join the british army and to fight in France. That led to a split in the Irish volunteers in which 15,000 or so, between 10 and 15,000, went with people under the charge of Eoin MacNeill. And they began to drift towards the idea of revolution. But McNeill would only go if there was two things happening. If the volunteers were going to be suppressed by the state and if there were arms coming from Germany and genuine prospect of success. So in the week before Easter 1916,
志愿军加入英国军队去法国作战。这导致爱尔兰志愿军分裂，其中大约1万5千人（在1万到1万5千人之间）跟随了欧恩·麦克尼尔领导的人。他们开始倾向于革命的思想。但麦克尼尔只有在两个条件同时满足的情况下才会行动：一是志愿军遭到国家镇压，二是德国能提供武器且有真正的成功希望。因此，在1916年复活节前的一周，
those guys who were set on revolution from the IRB took a document that was in Dublin Castle and I think the phrase in English politics is sexed it up and made it that the volunteers were about to be suppressed and convinced McNeill of that. And then they told McNeill there were guns coming from Germany. So McNeill agreed, everyone would rise on Easter Sunday morning. We would call for manoeuvres and we would use those manoeuvres
那些铁心要在爱尔兰共和兄弟会（IRB）领导下搞革命的人，拿到了都柏林城堡的一份文件——我想用英国政治的说法就是“润色”了一下——把它说成是志愿军即将遭到镇压，并以此说服了麦克尼尔。接着，他们告诉麦克尼尔，德国的枪支正在运来。于是麦克尼尔同意了，大家将在复活节星期天早晨发动起义。我们将以举行演习为名，利用这些演习
to take various strategic places around Dublin and that the country would be sized with Limerick as a base and everything would manoeuvre there and then everything would rise and the British would be overthrown. Now, the problem was when MacNeill heard that the casement had been captured and there were no guns coming. He balked at the idea. Number two, he began to believe that the castle document was a forgery. This document that said there was suppression. Well, it was the makings of a forgery, which had a basis in a real document that appears. But it was ultimately a forgery. If you change the document, it's a forgery.
占领都柏林周围的各个战略要地，并以利默里克为基地控制整个国家，一切都在那里集结，随后全面起义，推翻英国的统治。现在的问题是，当麦克尼尔听说凯斯门特被捕且没有武器运到时，他打退堂鼓了。第二，他开始相信都柏林城堡的文件是伪造的。这份声称存在镇压的文件。好吧，这可以说是伪造的雏形，它以一份真实出现的文件为基础。但它最终是一份伪造文件。如果你篡改了文件，它就是伪造的。
So yes, it's a long answer to a simple question. So McNeill issued countermanding orders, said that on Easter Sunday, there would now be no manoeuvres. He published a notice on the front page of the Sunday Independent, which best-selling paper in the country to cancel everything.
所以，是的，这是一个简单问题的长篇大论。因此，麦克尼尔下达了撤销命令，宣布复活节星期天将不再举行任何演习。他在全国畅销报纸《星期日独立报》的头版刊登了一则公告，取消所有活动。
So now the rebels with Pierce and Tom Clark, they're in Connolly, they're in a quandary. What do they do? They fear, they made a fateful decision. They said, we won't go on Sunday. We'll go on the Monday instead. The problem was they mobilized on Easter Monday morning and there was confusion in the ranks of all the volunteers.
现在，以皮尔斯和汤姆·克拉克为首的叛军，还有康纳利，陷入了两难境地。他们该怎么办？他们感到……他们做出了一项命运攸关的决定。他们说，我们周日不干了。我们改在周一动手。问题是，他们在复活节星期一早晨动员时，所有志愿军的队伍里都充满了混乱。
So there weren't 15,000 came out. In course of the whole week, fewer than 2,000 came out. And on the morning themselves, there were probably fewer than 1,000. So into this building here, just after noon, they gathered in Liberty Hall, just down along the river from us here, which was the headquarters, which had a sign hanging outside it. We serve neither King nor Kaiser. They walked out through the doors of there and they headed to various parts around the city in their mobilization. They walked through through the doors of there and they headed to various parts around the city in their mobilization. They walked through these doors here.
因此，出来的并不是15000人。在整个星期里，出来的人数不到2000人。而在早晨刚开始时，可能甚至不到1000人。就这样，正午刚过，他们聚集在离我们顺着河流不远处的自由大楼里，这里是总部，外面挂着一块标牌：“我们既不效忠国王，也不效忠凯撒”。他们走出了那里的门，在动员中前往城市的各个地方。他们走出了那里的门，在动员中前往城市的各个地方。他们走过了这些门。
There were five soldiers on duty. They shot a sergeant in the face and they took over the general post office. And wasn't there was one very unfortunate British soldier who was here buying stamps? Incredibly bad timing. His timing was not ideal. And apparently he got access to a bottle of brandy later in the week and he uh he took a lot of minding i think is the phrase that was uh that was bandied um so they walk in i mean a small group of them ultimately compared with the the 15 000 they were hoping for what's the reaction of the people of Dublin
当时有五名士兵在岗。他们朝一名中士的脸开枪，占领了邮政总局。当时不是还有一名非常倒霉的英国士兵正在这里买邮票吗？时机简直糟透了。他的时机很不理想。据说到那天晚些时候，他设法弄到了一瓶白兰地，他呃……他挺难照料的，我想这是当时到处流传的说法。所以他们走了进去——我是说，与他们希望的15000人相比，他们最终只是一小群人——都柏林人民对此作何反应呢？
when these guys pitch up and they say, listen, everybody, it's a revolution, a republic. I mean, the people who are buying stamps, going for lunch, going about their daily business, I'm guessing they're not swept. I mean, knowing crowds as I do in history, they're probably not swept up instantly by revolution enthusiasm, are they?
当这群人出现并宣布：“听着，各位，这是一场革命，是一个共和国！”时？我的意思是，那些正在买邮票、吃午饭、过着日常生活的人，我猜他们并没有被震撼。我是说，以我对历史上群众的了解，他们大概不会瞬间被革命的热情所席卷，对吧？
No, because they're used to people parading on the streets and now Pierce is outside in his uniform reading a proclamation of a republic which they can't conceive of.
没有，因为他们习惯了人们在街上游行，而现在皮尔斯穿着制服站在外面宣读共和国的宣言，这是他们无法想象的。
And there are people there who are mocking, there are people who've got family who are fighting in the British Army in the front, people looking at him
那里有人在嘲笑，有人有家人正在前线为英军作战，还有人看着他
in bemusement and of course there were others of course who were happy to see it as revolution. But it's what happens next is really important. The rebels then began to put up barricades around the city. So they begin to stop life in the city and they attack Dublin Castle. And it is at Dublin Castle that the first shots of the revolution are fired and a policeman is killed going in. Now we know in hindsight, and everybody says this military plan was terrible. Why didn't you take Dublin Castle?
感到困惑。当然，也有其他人很高兴看到这是一场革命。但接下来发生的事情非常重要。叛军随后开始在城市四周设置路障。因此，他们开始阻断城市的正常生活，并进攻都柏林城堡。正是在都柏林城堡，革命的第一枪打响了，一名警察在进入时被杀。现在我们事后诸葛亮地来看，所有人都说这个军事计划太糟糕了。你们为什么不占领都柏林城堡？
Why didn't you take Trinity College? Why did you take the list of buildings that you took? Why did you go to the GPO? Yes, it's a grand building on the best street in the city. The post office isn't the obvious place you would seize first. No, nor is Stephen's Green, where they built a trench in the middle of the green. Nor is the Four Accords. Not a bad building along the Liffey. But the thing about Dublin Castle, so the policeman who gets shot is unarmed. And I think they were what about kind of, there's one armed soldier in there. And the sense of Dublin Castle is this powerful nerve centre of imperial control.
为什么不占领三一学院？你们为什么会选了那个建筑清单？为什么要去邮政总局？是的，那是城里最好的街道上一座宏伟的建筑。邮政总局并不是你首先应该占领的显眼地方。不，圣斯蒂芬绿地也不是，他们在绿地中央挖了一条战壕。四法院也不是。沿利菲河畔倒是一座不错的建筑。但关于都柏林城堡的关键在于，中枪的那个警察是没有武装的。我想里面大概只有一个武装士兵。都柏林城堡给人的感觉是帝国控制的中枢神经系统。
And actually it seems to have been completely hopeless. Burrell was in London for the weekend. Other officials were away. And lots of officers were off at the races, weren't they? They were at the Irish Grand National,
而事实上，它似乎完全无能为力。伯雷尔周末在伦敦。其他官员不在。许多军官都去看赛马了，不是吗？他们在爱尔兰障碍赛马大会上，
which was down in Ferry House. But it tells you how little they expected to be a revolution. They may have been worried on the Sunday, but after all, they'd got casement.
那是举办在费里豪斯的。但这说明他们对爆发革命的预期有多么低。他们在周日可能曾感到担忧，但毕竟，他们已经抓住了凯斯门特。
They'd got the guns. They'd seen the countermanding order. There's no evidence that these guys are going to go out on the Monday and stage a revolution. So why won't I enjoy my Easter Monday? Why wouldn't I go to the races? And the rebels didn't know. It's easy to say now, well, there were no guns there. There weren't 200 soldiers. Why didn't you take Dublin Castle and hold it? They might've considered it to be just too difficult to do it. So they, but they took city hall,
他们找到了枪支。他们看到了撤销命令。没有证据表明这些人会在周一出门发动革命。那我为什么不好好享受我的复活节星期一呢？我为什么不去赛马呢？叛军当时并不知道。现在说“哦，那里没有枪，也没有200名士兵，你们为什么不占领都柏林城堡并坚守呢”很容易。他们可能认为这实在太难做到了。所以他们……但他们占领了市政厅，
which is right beside Dublin Castle, a formidable building. And actually, if anybody wants to read an account of that, have a look online at the Bureau of Military History account of Harry Colley, who was a C-O-L-L-E-Y who fought in that revolution. And he tells a really dramatic, vivid story of it.
它就在都柏林城堡旁边，是一座令人生畏的建筑。事实上，如果有人想阅读相关的记载，可以上网看看哈里·科利（Harry Colley，姓氏拼写为C-O-L-L-E-Y，曾参加那场革命）在军事历史局的记述。他讲述了一个非常戏剧性、生动的故事。
My favorite thing they take is the Jacob's Biscuit Factory. That was what I was going to ask. Why on earth do they take the Jacob's Biscuit Factory? There is no obvious reason why. That was a lot of biscuits. That was the case. They also took a mill, Bolin's Mills, and they took the South Dublin Union,
我最喜欢他们占领的地方是雅各布饼干厂。这也是我正要问的。他们到底为什么要占领雅各布饼干厂？这没有任何明显的理由。那有非常多的饼干。确实如此。他们还占领了一座磨坊，博兰磨坊，并且占领了南都柏林工会，
which is a site of, anyone who's been to Dublin will know James's Hospital. But not Trinity College, which is great. I mean, that would be a very strong place to hold, wouldn't it? Yes, and if you've got significant numbers with you, you might take Trinity College. But the plan for the Rising has been lost. So they say there were three copies made of the plan for the Rising.
去过都柏林的人都知道那是詹姆斯医院的所在地。但他们没有占领三一学院，这真棒。我是说，那会是一个非常坚固的据点，不是吗？是的，如果你身边有相当数量的人，你可能会占领三一学院。但起义的计划已经丢失了。所以他们说，起义计划只制作了三份副本。
They were so worried about informers. They didn't make loads of copies, didn't disperse them, and the plans were lost. We don't know exactly what they intended to do before the mobilisation ended up the way it is. And probably the most bizarre decision was actually to go
他们太担心告密者了。他们没有复印很多份，也没有分散保存，结果计划丢失了。在动员最终变成现在这样之前，我们并不知道他们原本打算做什。而可能最怪诞的决定，其实是去
into Stephens Green, which visitors to Dublin will know is a beautiful public space at the top of Ravenswick where they dug a trench in the manner of modern warfare. Well, isn't that because
占领圣斯蒂芬绿地——去过都柏林的游客都知道，那是拉文斯维克顶端一个美丽的公共场所——他们竟在那里按照现代战争的方式挖了一条战壕。嗯，难道不是因为
they thought, you know, they think modern warfare is all about trenches. Yes. The Great War, France and Flanders. So obviously what you need to do if you're trying to capture a city you know they think modern warfare is all about trenches the great war France and Flanders
他们以为，你知道的，他们认为现代战争全都是关于战壕的。是的。大战，法国和法兰德斯。所以很显然，如果你试图攻占一座城市，你知道他们认为现代战争全都是关于战壕的，大战，法国和法兰德斯，
so obviously what you need to do if you're trying to capture a city is dig a massive big trench in the middle and prepare for you know
那么很显然，如果你试图攻占一座城市，你需要做的事就是在中间挖一条巨大的深沟，然后准备好，你知道的，
to repel attackers disappointingly though there are high buildings all around us where snipers which leaves you open and it was
击退进攻者。然而令人失望的是，周围全都是高大建筑，上面有狙击手，这让你完全暴露在外，而且这是一场
an unmitigated disaster and they went through across Stevens Green to the Royal College of Surgeons where they stayed the rest of the week there. And my favourite detail
彻底的灾难。他们穿过圣斯蒂芬绿地，撤到了皇家外科医学院，并在那里度过了接下来的一周。而我最喜欢的细节
almost from the Easter Rising is that when the British duly arrive and there's kind of fighting over St. Stevens Green, that there's a kind of twice daily truce where the park keeper is allowed to go in
几乎可以说是关于复活节起义的——当英国人如期抵达，圣斯蒂芬绿地周围爆发战斗时，每天会有两次短暂停火，允许公园看守员进去
and feed the ducks, which I think reflects very well on both sides. I think, I think that's true. I think that's true. I think it's matched only as a piece of trivia from the rising by the fact that two people who fought in the rising, John Loder and Arthur Shields ended up starring in a Hollywood film,
喂鸭子，我认为这很好地反映了交战双方的人性。我想，我想这是真的。我认为这是真的。我觉得关于这场起义，唯一能与之媲美的冷门趣事是，有两个参加过起义的人——约翰·洛德和亚瑟·谢尔兹——后来竟主演了一部好莱坞电影，
which won five Oscars in the 1950s, a John Ford film. So that's, I think the only thing that may match. But isn't there a bloke as well, his mum comes to take him home? Yeah, his mum
那部约翰·福特导演的电影在20世纪50年代赢得了五项奥斯卡奖。所以我想，这是唯一能与之相比的事了。不过难道没有一个家伙，他妈妈来把他带回家吗？是的，他妈妈
would call to the GPO and tell him to stop that mess and then go home. But he came back the next day. Oh, okay. The next day there
会跑到邮电总局，叫他别搞那些乱七八糟的，然后回家。但他第二天又回来了。哦，好吧。第二天
was no, he didn't leave after that. So to go back to the Monday, by Monday afternoon, the city has not risen. And many of the
没有……他之后并没有离开。所以回到星期一，到了星期一下午，这座城市并没有起义。而城里的许多
people in the city when they find out, am I right in this, that many of the people when they find out what's going on are furious appalled they think it's a i mean not everybody of course there is a whole you can't generalize but they haven't had the reaction the unbridled enthusiasm that they might have hoped for yeah no that's absolutely clear i think it sometimes overplayed the extent to which people opposed what they did because the turn came so quickly afterwards and after the executions that it feels to me too much to say that, oh, the city was appalled, the city was disgusted. There were definitely people who were disgusted and appalled by it, but I would be slow to say how general that was. There were people amazed. But people often seem to say that it's women in particular who are hostile to it. And there are comparisons to the, the trickateurs, the women who would knit in front of the guillotine in the French revolution, that women are so hostile that the volunteers are often kind of quite nervous about the violence that they might
人在发现情况时——我没记错吧？许多人在发现发生了什么之后感到愤怒、震惊，他们认为这是一场……当然不是所有人，你不能一概而论，但他们并没有获得他们可能期望的那种狂热的支持。是的，不，这绝对是很清楚的。我认为人们有时会夸大反对他们所作所为的人数，因为局势随后的转向太快了，在处决发生之后，让我觉得断言“哦，全城都感到震惊，全城都感到厌恶”未免有些过头了。确实有人对此感到厌恶和震惊，但我不敢说这种情绪有多普遍。确实有人感到震惊。但人们似乎经常说，尤其是女性对起义抱有敌意。这让人联想到法国大革命中那些在断头台前织毛衣的女性（les tricoteuses），人们认为女性是如此充满敌意，以至于志愿军对她们可能引发的暴力行为
inflict on them. Yes. And again, that is said, but again, probably the best contemporary account of The Rising is a beautiful book by James Stevens, which is called The Insurrection in Dublin. And he talks about that idea of resentment at the rebels from particularly women on the streets. And so we can't deny that that's the case. It's the extent of it and how quickly it changed, I think, is that issue, number one. Number two, he has a brilliant line in it when he talks about the rumours that were sweeping Dublin when this happened. Cork had been taken. Munster was in rebel hands. The English were surrounded and in their barracks and couldn't leave. The country had risen. As he said himself, rumours were created and winged in the course of that week and they spread through the city. But the British are not surrounded and presumably troops are starting to be mobilised and brought in to try and pacify
常常感到相当紧张。是的。同样，这种说法确实存在。不过，关于起义最好的当代记录，大概是詹姆斯·斯蒂芬斯（James Stephens）写的一本名为《都柏林起义》（The Insurrection in Dublin）的美丽著作。他在书中谈到了这种对叛军的怨恨情绪，尤其是来自街头女性的怨恨。所以我们无法否认这种情况确实存在。我认为问题在于这种情绪的规模以及它转变的速度有多快，这是第一点。第二，他在书中有一句精彩绝伦的话，当时他谈到起义发生时席卷都柏林的种种谣言：科克已被攻占；芒斯特落入叛军手中；英国人被包围在兵营里无法离开；全国已经起义。正如他自己所说，那一周里谣言被炮制并插上了翅膀，在全城扩散开来。但英国人并没有被包围，而且可以想见，军队已经开始动员并被调集进来试图平息
the rising. So what's the process by which the British come into Dublin? They come in without any difficulty at all because the rebels have not cut off the strategic ways into the city from Kildare, from the Curragh camp. So they come in easily. They stabilize the situation in Dublin Castle. It's clear by Monday evening that it's fine. By Tuesday, martial law has been declared. They bring four 18 pound artillery guns up from McLean and they're set up near Trinity College there on Westmoreland Street. And they begin to send troops over from Wales. They put troops on the ships. And when those troops arrive on the Wednesday, they cannot believe how eloquent the English being spoken by the people they meet are because they thought they were going to France. Yeah, of course. But even, I mean, the extraordinary thing. So within
起义。那么，英国人进入都柏林的整个过程是怎样的？他们毫无困难地进城了，因为叛军没有切断从基尔代尔、从库拉训练营通往城市的战略要道。所以他们轻而易举地进来了。他们稳定了都柏林城堡的局势。到周一晚上，局势显然已经无碍。到了周二，戒严令已经宣布。他们从麦克莱恩调来了四门18磅野战炮，并将它们架设在三一学院附近韦斯特莫兰街上。他们开始从威尔士调运军队。他们把军队装上船。当这些军队在周三抵达时，他们简直不敢相信他们遇到的人所说的英语竟然如此流畅，因为他们本以为自己是要去法国。是的，当然。但即使是……我是说，这真是非同寻常。所以在
arguably less than a day, the final outcome is decided, right? Because they're, you know, it's pretty obvious probably by nightfall on the Monday that this isn't going to be a successful revolution that, you, that Dublin Castle still stands, the British are on their way, this is going to be snuffed out. Oh yeah, and there are, above us here, the Irish Republic flag, the green flag with the harp on it, is flying at one end, the tricolour,
可以说不到一天的时间里，最终的结局就已经决定了，对吧？因为……你知道的，大概在周一入夜时分，情况就已经很明显了：这将不会是一场成功的革命，你知道的，都柏林城堡依然屹立，英国人在赶来的路上，这场起义将被扑灭。哦，是的。就在我们头顶上方，爱尔兰共和国的旗帜——带有竖琴图案的绿旗——在一端迎风飘扬，而三色旗——
the green, white and orange is flying at the other end. But the rebel headquarters, how does it communicate with everybody else? There are barricades at each end but the rebel headquarters how does it communicate with everybody else there are barricades at the end of the each end of the street with British soldiers at each end of them
绿色、白色和橙色——在另一端飘扬。但叛军总部如何与其他人进行沟通呢？街道两端都有路障，但叛军总部如何与其他人进行沟通呢？街道两端都有路障，两端都有英国士兵把守。
there's a smell and sound of revolution yeah there's gunshots everywhere James Stevens writes
空气中弥漫着革命的气味和声音，是的，到处都是枪声。詹姆斯·斯蒂芬斯写道，
he talks about writing this as he hears shots in the streets there are horses dying on the street and later there are wild horses
他谈到自己一边在街头听到枪声一边进行写作的情景，街上有马匹死去，后来还有野马
running up and down the street and then there's looting everywhere around the city and they loot cricket bats don't they they loot they loot I later there are wild horses running up and down the street and then there's looting everywhere around the city and they loot cricket bats don't they they loot they'd loot i think there are some incredible scenes so there's the scene of five people pushing through a dublin street carrying a grand piano five of them which has been looted and there are people who loot cricket bats and balls and they play cricket on the bottom of Sackville Street. And there's a
在街上狂奔，然后全城到处都在发生洗劫。他们甚至抢劫板球拍，不是吗？他们抢劫，他们抢劫……后来有野马在街上狂奔，然后全城到处都在发生洗劫。他们甚至抢劫板球拍，不是吗？他们抢劫，他们抢劫……我想有一些难以置信的场景：比如有五个人推着一架从都柏林街道上抢来的大三角钢琴艰难前行，还有人抢劫板球拍和球，然后在萨克维尔街底打起板球。还有一个
beautiful phrase and poignant and desperately sad one about, which James Stevens writes about a group of children who've looted a sweet shop and they get to taste things, but they most likely have never tasted before and may never again in the rest of their lives. Almost all the people we've talked about, apart from Thomas talking about the crowds, have been men but there are women involved in this in the Easter Rising too
优美动人、充满辛酸和绝望悲哀的片段，詹姆斯·斯蒂芬斯在书中写到一群孩子抢劫了一家糖果店，他们尝到了以前很可能从未尝过、余生也可能再尝不到的味道。我们谈到的几乎所有人，除了汤姆谈到群众时提到的那些人之外，基本上都是男性，但复活节起义中也有女性参与，
aren't there? Yes and they're extremely important to the Rising and to the idea of the Rising as well and they run from
不是吗？是的，她们对起义以及起义的理念都极其重要，她们的背景各异，从
somebody like Constance Markievicz who was from the Gore Booth family very, Lissadel House very familiar to Yeats and she
像康斯坦斯·马基维奇（Constance Markievicz）这样出身于戈尔博思家族、拥有利瑟尔庄园（叶芝非常熟悉的地方）的人，到其他人……
is a figure who was in Stephen's Green, was involved in the Irish Citizen Army. Kind of saw herself and was seen by others as the leader of that group who were up there and who were treated to Dublin Cassettes. She fired apparent claims to have killed somebody or there are claims that she shot one person there. There are others such as Margaret Skinner who came from Scotland
她是一个曾出现在圣斯蒂芬绿地、参与爱尔兰公民军的人物。她自视并且也被其他人视为那个占据那里并向都柏林城堡开枪的群体的领导者。据称她曾向某人开枪，或者有说法称她在那里射杀了一个人。还有其他人，比如从苏格兰来到这里
to come over and fight. And Countess Markievicz has a tremendous costume, doesn't she? And this also seems to be part of the Easter Rising is that people want to look good for it.
参战的玛格丽特·斯金纳（Margaret Skinner）。马基维奇伯爵夫人有一身极其抢眼的行头，不是吗？这也似乎是复活节起义的一部分，人们希望在起义时看起来很帅气。
The imagery of the Rising matters and it certainly, she was wearing a hat with ostrich feathers and it was quite the statement I think when it was out there and it has led, I think, to an unfortunate image of her as being excessively vain. And there is no doubt she had a certain vanity and do that. But she was also famous for her diligence and her committee work and her willingness to do all the hard work as well as she wasn't there for the glamour of revolution. She had worked exceptionally hard to create that revolution. And if you look at the women who were in the rising, they span people from that elite of Irish society, right down to people who came from the very poorest circumstances and found a sense of liberation from being treated as equals within the Irish citizen army. Now we can't dress
起义的视觉形象非常重要，当然，她当时戴着一顶饰有鸵鸟羽毛的帽子，我觉得这在当时是一个相当醒目的宣言，但也导致了一个不幸的印象，即认为她过于虚荣。毫无疑问，她确实有一定的虚荣心。但她也以勤奋、委员会工作以及愿意承担所有苦差事而闻名，她并不是为了革命的浮华才到那里的。为了促成那场革命，她曾付出过异常艰辛的努力。如果你看看参加起义的女性，她们跨越了从爱尔兰社会精英一直到出身最贫困环境的人，后者在爱尔兰公民军中被视作平等的人，从而找到了一种解放感。现在我们无法掩饰
this up. We cannot pretend that all the men who were out in 1916 reviewed women as their equals. It's obvious that they didn't, and they certainly didn't. Some people didn't want them there at all. Some men didn't want them there at all, and some definitely didn't want them firing guns. And they were seen as being there to do the catering or the medical work. So it's not, we have to be careful here in how that is presented. And what about the British? When these soldiers arrive, they think they're going to France and they find that they're in a city within the United Kingdom.
这一点。我们不能假装1916年走上街头的的所有男性都将女性视为平等的人。很明显他们并没有，而且绝对没有。有些人根本不想让她们去那里。有些男性根本不想让她们出现在那里，有些人则坚决反对她们开枪。她们被视为只是去负责后勤或医疗工作的。所以在这一点上，我们在呈现时必须小心谨慎。那么英国人呢？当这些士兵抵达时，他们以为自己是要去法国，却发现自己身处联合王国境内的某座城市中。
What is their take on what is happening? Well, first of all, you look at the soldiers who walk in from Kingstown, now Dun Laoghaire, in the south side of Dublin. They walk in, a group of them goes
他们对正在发生的事有什么看法？首先，你看那些从金斯敦（现在的邓莱里，位于都柏林南城）走过来的士兵。他们步行入城，其中一群人
on the wider road in through Donnybrook and they're fine. They make it to Stevens Green in that area without problems. But there's a group come in along Northumberland Street and they've been set up by an outpost from Avon De Valera's crowd who are in Boland Mills. And they run into an ambush. And there are the guts of 250 British soldiers who are killed or wounded, being caught in the crossfire between about 17 or 18 rebels. One rebel talks about how the gun was too hot to handle. He'd been firing it that often. And that
经由宽阔的道路穿过多尼布鲁克，一路上平安无事。他们顺利到达了圣斯蒂芬绿地那一带。但有一群人沿着诺森伯兰街走过来时，遭到了埃文·德瓦莱拉手下（驻守在博兰磨坊）一支前哨部队的伏击。他们陷入了埋伏。大约有250名英国士兵在约17到18名叛军的交叉火力中伤亡。一名叛军谈到他的枪因为开火太频繁而烫得无法上手。而那
was almost like it was charge of the light brigade idea that we will go through this road. Or I guess battle of the Somme, coming out of a trench and discharging. Which comes in very quickly afterwards, of course. And again, by the way, it's a formidable foundation stone for Ulster Unionism and central to Ulster Unionist identity. But in that, it is clear on Wednesday that there is only going to be one result.
几乎就像是轻骑兵冲锋的想法——我们要冲过这条街。或者我想象成索姆河战役，从战壕里冲出来开火的场景。当然，这种联想很快就会浮现出来。而且顺便说一句，这对阿尔斯特统一主义来说是一个极具分量的基石，也是阿尔斯特统一主义认同的核心。但在当时，到了周三，结果已经很明显了。
If there were any doubt, because the Helga, a gunboat, comes up the Liffey and stops, first of all, beside Liberty Hall, which is along, beside the Customs House. There's nobody in Liberty Hall, but it's Liberty hall, which is along beside the customs house. There's nobody in Liberty hall,
如果还有什么疑问的话，因为一艘名为“海尔加”号的炮艇顺着利菲河开上来，首先停在了海关大楼旁边、自由大楼的旁边。自由大楼里没有人，但它是……自由大楼就在海关大楼旁边。自由大楼里没有人，
but it's a statement. This is where the rebels left from. This is the home of anti-capitalism in Dublin. And they blew it to pieces. Meanwhile, by Thursday, this building here is being subjected to a barrage of artillery shells and incendiary shells coming from across the river.
但这是一个姿态。这是叛军出发的地方。这是都柏林反资本主义的大本营。他们把它轰成了碎片。与此同时，到了周四，河对岸飞来的炮弹和燃烧弹开始对这座建筑进行狂轰滥炸。
They're not like attempting to storm the buildings. Storming buildings in urban warfare would have been incredibly difficult. A lot of loss of life. So they just take this place and they essentially burn it. So there is an incredible description of that. So this is Louisa Norway. She is who is Louisa Norway?
他们并没有试图强攻这些建筑。在城市巷战中强攻建筑会极其困难，并会导致大量人员伤亡。所以他们只是攻占了这个地方，并基本上把它烧成了废墟。对此有一个令人难以置信的描述。这个人是路易莎·挪威（Louisa Norway）。路易莎·挪威是谁？
She is the wife of the head of the post office after norway and so she she wrote it seemed as if the whole city was on fire the glow extending right across the heavens and the red glare hundreds of feet high while above the roar of the fires the whole air seemed vibrating with the noise of the great guns and machine guns it was an inferno we remained spell bound and i can't tell you how i longed for you to see it so the sense there that this is a horror but also an incredible spectacle and sackville street as it was then was the most handsome city in dublin i mean the most handsome street in dublin yes and as the freeman's journal wrote afterwards the most handsome street in europe had been destroyed
她是挪威事件后邮政总局局长的妻子。她写道：“整座城市看起来都在燃烧，火光一直延伸到整个天际，红色耀眼的光芒高达数百英尺。在熊熊烈火的轰鸣声中，整个空气似乎都在大炮和机枪的轰鸣声中震颤。这是一个炼狱。我们惊呆了，无法言语，我真盼着你能亲眼来看看。”所以那种感觉是，这是一场人间地狱，但也是一处不可思议的奇观。当时的萨克维尔街曾是都柏林最漂亮的城市……我是说都柏林最漂亮的街道，是的。正如《弗里曼日报》事后所写的那样，全欧洲最漂亮的街道已经被摧毁，
and turned into a room like you would see at Ypres. And it was a simple case. We look at the GPO and this, for people who don't know it, there's a couple of hundred meters between the GPO and the Liffey. All of this was flattened. Everything was blown out of it. The rebels had had to retreat back along there. And there was no doubt the overwhelming gunpowder. They didn't try and storm the building, which would have cost enormous loss of life. So they just put shells in. So by the end of the week,
变成了一处你在伊珀尔才能见到的废墟。事情很简单。我们看看邮政总局，对于不了解情况的人来说，邮政总局和利菲河之间只有两百米左右的距离。这一切都被夷为平地。里面的一切都被炸得粉碎。叛军不得不沿着原路撤退。毫无疑问，那是压倒性的火药威力。他们没有试图强攻这座建筑，那会付出巨大的生命代价。所以他们只是打进炮弹。因此，到了周末，
the rebels, I mean, they've held out for a few days, but it's perfectly obvious to Pierce to hold out much further would involve colossal loss of civilian life. There's just no points.
叛军……我是说，他们坚持了几天，但对于皮尔斯来说，再坚持下去会导致平民的巨大伤亡，这已经是显而易见的了。完全没有意义。
And he agrees to surrender. On Friday, they're forced to leave this building here to evacuate through the back entrance or through a side entrance onto Moore Street. There's a retreat with a couple of hundred people. James Connolly's on a stretcher. He's not able to walk.
于是他同意投降。周五，他们被迫离开这座建筑，从后门或侧门撤退到摩尔街。这是一次有几百人参加的撤退。詹姆斯·康纳利躺在担架上。他无法行走，
His ankle is gone. Plunkett is sick. There are a lot of people in a bad way, but the heat is too much to say. The timbers from the roof are cascading down there's talk about the intense heat and everybody's hungry
他的脚踝废了。普伦克特生病了。许多人的状况都很糟糕，但热浪实在太盛，无法形容。屋顶的木梁哗啦啦地往下塌，大家都在谈论那股炽热的高温，每个人都很饥饿，
and they've all been Right, even in the biscuit factory because apparently they're complaining that they're so fed up with eating biscuits that they'd do anything to have some bread
而且他们已经……没错，甚至在饼干厂里也是如此，因为显然他们抱怨说吃饼干吃得太腻了，只要能吃上一口面包他们什么都愿意做。
which is And what happens then is they withdraw down Henry Street and onto Moore Street where there's a last stand on the Friday night but by Saturday morning,
而接下来发生的事情是，他们沿亨利街撤退到摩尔街，并在周五晚上进行了最后一次抵抗，但到了周六早晨，
Plunkett is sending Elizabeth O'Farrell under a white flag to suggest a surrender and looking for terms. And it's told back to say it's unconditional surrender or no surrender. And they go for the unconditional? They go for the unconditional surrender.
普伦克特派遣伊丽莎白·奥法雷尔（Elizabeth O'Farrell）举着白旗去商谈投降并寻求条件。得到的回复是：无条件投降，否则免谈。他们接受了无条件投降吗？他们接受了无条件投降。
And Elizabeth O'Farrell is then dispatched around the city to go to the different garrisons. And you talked about the view of the city being on fire, but the rebel garrisons were untouched elsewhere. Broadly speaking, there was trouble around the forecourts. There was street fighting around that area, which led to a lot of civilian death, many killed by the British army who couldn't distinguish between rebels and civilian as they came through. South Dublin Union was left untouched. Bowlands Mills was left largely untouched. So they were going,
随后伊丽莎白·奥法雷尔被派往全市各个驻军点。你刚才谈到城市在燃烧的景象，但其他地方的叛军驻军并没有受到触动。大致来说，四法院周边发生了一些冲突。该地区周围的巷战导致了大量平民伤亡，许多人在英军推进时被无法分清叛民和百姓的英军士兵所杀。南都柏林工会完好无损。博兰磨坊也基本完好无损。所以他们当时的想法是：
wait, we don't need to surrender. And the country hadn't risen, but Enniscorthy had been taken. And Enniscorthy, they're going, why do we have to do this? Out in Ashburn, there'd been a small rising in Ashburn where there were running battles with the RSC and British army. They don't want to stop. But they do stop eventually.
等等，我们不需要投降。虽然全国没有起义，但恩斯科西被攻占了。在恩斯科西，他们觉得：我们为什么非得这么做？在阿什本，曾发生过一场规模不大的起义，当地与皇家爱尔兰宪兵队（RIC）及英军展开了游击战。他们不想停下来。但他们最终还是停了下来。
They do stop within a couple of days and it's clear that the Republic lies in ruins. But this is the fascinating thing, isn't it? So the rising has been a complete failure. Militarily, you know, it hasn't worked, but the reason we're even doing this podcast is because politically it is a resounding success. And now the usual accounts that I'm guessing that most people listening to this will have, who know about it will have at the back of their minds is the British defeated the rising and then completely screwed it up by their their violent
他们在几天内最终停了下来，很显然，共和国成了一片废墟。但这正是迷人的地方，不是吗？所以起义完全失败了。从军事上讲，你知道的，它没有成功，但我们之所以做这个播客，正是因为它在政治上取得了巨大的成功。现在，我猜听这个节目的绝大多数了解这段历史的人，脑海中通常的看法是：英国人镇压了起义，然后通过他们的暴力
repression and by the cruelty of the executions and all this now i both tom and i were listening to a series of lectures by your old tutor professor michael lafferman ucd who compared it with the the paris commune of 1871 for the parisune, he said 20,000 people were executed. Is it 16 executed? Including casement. Including casement at the end of these. So in other words, actually when you look at people repressing rebellions, well, the British
镇压和残酷的处决等手段，把事情彻底搞砸了。现在，汤姆和我当时都在听你的老导师迈克尔·拉夫曼教授（UCD的迈克尔·拉夫曼教授）的一系列讲座，他将这次起义与1871年的巴黎公社进行了比较。对于巴黎公社，他说有两万人被处决。而这里被处决的是多少人？16人。包括凯斯门特。在这些处决的最后包括了凯斯门特。换句话说，实际上当你看到人们镇压叛乱时，英国人
don't execute loads of... But he also makes the point that this is seen as treachery and treason. In the middle of a world war. In the middle of a world war where Britain is facing a kind of deadly threat that the rebels have sided with the Kaiser. But also, does he not also make the point, he says for Asquith's government, it's
并没有处决大量……但他同时也指出，这被视为背叛和叛国。在世界大战期间。在英国面临致命威胁、叛军站在凯撒一边的世界大战期间。而且，难道他没有指出这一点吗？他说对于阿斯奎斯政府来说，
completely and utterly inconceivable that they would say oh chaps, that was poor form. The centre of Dublin lies in five years prison, then you can come out and be rehabilitated. I mean, that's never going to happen, right? And to add to that, the rebel leaders themselves knew they were going to be executed beforehand there was no there was no surprise in this right but how then does it become such a
他们绝对、完全无法想象自己会说：“哦，伙计们，那行为可真糟糕。都柏林市中心被毁了。去判五年监禁，然后你就可以出来接受平反了。”我的意思是，这永远不可能发生，对吧？不仅如此，叛军领袖自己事先就知道他们会被处决，这根本没有任何意外，对吧？那么，为什么它会变成这样一个
massive issue i mean these guys we've come from downstairs the statues are there the sense of martyrdom the sense that these guys gave their lives against a hideously repressive enemy, and that this became an absolute motivating, I don't want to say legend, because that makes it sound like it didn't happen. It did happen. The extent to which it became… It changed utterly. A terrible beauty is born. Right. How did it then become become against the background of
极其重大议题呢？我的意思是，我们从楼下来，那些雕像就在那里，殉道者的那种感觉，这些人为了对抗一个极其暴虐的敌人而献出生命的感觉，这变成了一种绝对的激励——我不想称之为传奇，因为那听起来像是没发生过一样。它确实发生了。它在多大程度上变成了一种……彻底改变了。“一种可怕的美诞生了。”对。在
the slaughter in the trenches how does it become this dare i say tom sacral it is a story for nationalism oh it is a sacral story and it's the answer is because of the executions because it doesn't matter what happened in paris it didn't matter these things and it comes back to this idea where i disagree with the idea that there was widespread revulsion around the place. There is an underlying current there, which is looking for a reason. And the reason you find is in the executions. And you can see it in the middle of the executions. The executions began on the 3rd of May and they ran for 10 days.
战壕里的血腥屠杀的背景下，它究竟是如何演变成——请允许我冒昧地说，汤姆——一个具有神圣色彩的民族主义故事的呢？哦，它确实是一个神圣的故事，答案就在于那些处决。因为巴黎发生了什么并不重要，这些事情都不重要，这就回到了我不同意“当时全城普遍存在厌恶情绪”这一观点的看法。那里存在着一种寻找理由的潜流。而你找到的理由就在于那些处决。你可以在处决的过程中看到这一点。处决从5月3日开始，持续了10天。
And that was a mistake because by the middle of the 10 days, there are people looking for clemency. And when you have people looking for clemency, you have to deny clemency. And it becomes a story as much as the execution that actually irish nationalists are holding the british to quite high standards that they feel that the british have then failed to to maintain is there an element of that i wouldn't think so i think they're just people they're just looking for reasons to i think you're looking for reasons and if you look at it it happens immediately and there's a roundup afterwards which is a a disaster. They corral three and a half thousand people. Loads of people are sent to Wales and interned and people are moved to different places. They lift all the wrong people as well as who are rebels there. There's stories coming out, but also now the factory of nationalist grievance has something to work with. It has two
这是一个错误，因为在这10天的中期，开始有人寻求宽大处理。而当有人寻求宽大处理时，你就必须拒绝宽大处理。它变成了一个故事，正如处决本身一样——实际上爱尔兰民族主义者对英国人抱有相当高的期望，他们觉得英国人未能保持这种标准。这里面有这种成分吗？我不这么认为。我认为他们只是普通人，他们只是在寻找借口去……我认为你是在寻找借口。如果你细看，这一切都是立刻发生的。事后还进行了大搜捕，这真是一场
things. It has, sorry, it has two things. It has the fight now because there has been a redemption through resurrection and it has the treatment afterwards to work with. One other extraordinary consequence of this is that one group
灾难。他们圈捕了三千五百人。大量人员被送往威尔士关押，人们被转移到不同的地方。他们不仅抓了叛军，还抓错了所有人。各种消息不断传出，但现在，民族主义满腹牢骚的“加工厂”有了可以利用的东西。它有了两样东西。它有……抱歉，它有两样东西。它现在有了这场斗争，因为通过复活节起义实现了某种救赎；它还有事后的对待方式可资利用。另一个非同寻常的后果是，有一个群体
who you've not mentioned once is Sinn Féin. Sinn Féin, which had been a monarchist party. Arthur Griffith was a monarchist. He wanted a kind of Austro-Hungarian system. And the British don't really know what Sinn Fein is and say, this is all Sinn Fein's work. This is a Sinn Fein uprising. And they basically,
你连一次都没有提到过，那就是新芬党。新芬党曾经是一个君主主义政党。亚瑟·格里菲思是个君主主义者。他想要一种奥匈帝国式的系统。而英国人其实并不知道新芬党是什么，便宣称：“这都是新芬党的阴谋。这是一场新芬党起义。”基本上，
the reaction to the Easter Rising creates Sinn Fein as a kind of, as a mass revolutionary party, I guess. Does it? Is that right? And it begins by things like Sinn Féin being named. So for example, the Irish Times published a handbook, which is a huge seller, sells out of the rebellion, a couple of hundred pages with pictures and portraits of the leaders,
对复活节起义的反应使新芬党变成了一种大众革命政党，我想是这样吗？是这样的吗？而且它是通过诸如新芬党被点名之类的事情开始的。例如，《爱尔兰时报》出版了一本非常畅销的手册，详细记述了叛乱，有几百页，配有领袖们的照片和肖像，
and they call it the Sinn Féin Rebellion. So the idea, Sinn Féin is an idea. It's an accumulation of the idea, and Sinn Féin rebellion. So the idea Sinn Féin is an idea. It's an accumulation of the idea and Sinn Féin in Irish means ourselves. And it captures an idea beautifully. Now Sinn Féin had nothing practical to do with the rebellion at all, but it now becomes a vehicle for people to push into. Right. And push they do. But it's amazing.
他们把它叫做“新芬党起义”。所以，新芬党是一个理念。它是这种理念的积累，“新芬党起义”。所以，新芬党是一个理念。它是这种理念的积累，而在爱尔兰语中，“新芬”（Sinn Féin）的意思是“我们自己”。这个名字完美地捕捉了一种理念。现在，新芬党实际上与这场叛乱没有任何实质关系，但它现在成了人们投身其中的一个政治载体。没错。而且他们也确实投入进去了。但真是令人惊异。
It's amazing some of the things that happen. Within a month, there are prisoners who've been wrongly lifted or had nothing to do with the rising are coming back on ships and they're being met at the quay by loads of people wearing tricolors. A year after, there are requiem masses
有些事情的发生简直令人惊叹。在一个月内，那些被错误逮捕或与起义毫无关系的囚犯乘船归来，码头上挤满了身披三色旗欢迎他们的人群。起义一年后，人们为
for the executed of 1916. Huge crowds are going. There is now taunting of the soldiers in the streets. A year after the rebellion, on Easter Monday, 1917, a group of people come here to the rubble of this site and they gather to say the Irish Republic is not dead, that the Irish Republic transcends time, that Pearson Connolly and Clark and Kant and MacDiarmida,
1916年被处决的烈士举行了安魂弥撒。成群结队的民众前往参加。街头上开始出现对士兵的嘲弄。叛乱一年后的复活节星期一（1917年），一群人来到这个遗址的废墟前，聚集在一起宣告爱尔兰共和国并未消亡，爱尔兰共和国超越了时间的限制，皮尔斯、康纳利、克拉克、坎特和麦克迪尔玛达……
by the very fact of establishing their provisional government, by signing that proclamation, by leading revival, had made certain the idea that there could be no unity. So that raises a wonderful counterfactual. What if the rising had been cancelled? What if, you know, the casement, the failure of the gun running that you started this part of the episode with, what if the rising doesn't happen? Is the course of Irish history different or would the trigger have come at some point in the 1910s anyway?
通过建立他们的临时政府、签署那份宣言、领导复兴这一事实，已经确定了不可能实现统一的观念。这就引出了一个极好的反事实假设：如果起义被取消了呢？如果正如你在这集节目开头所说的那样，凯斯门特被捕、武器走私失败了呢，如果起义没有发生呢？爱尔兰历史的进程会有所不同，还是说在2010年代的某个时候，导火索终究还是会被点燃？
Yeah, it's a brilliant question. And this idea of the counterfactual of this period has been looked at by, say, for example, someone like Professor Alvin Jackson up in Edinburgh, a brilliant historian, who's looked at what would happen if home rule had been granted, for example. And it's one of those things that it's really difficult. What I can say is there is a strain of Irish society which never accepted the idea of a United Kingdom. And in the middle, there was a huge swathe of population who, they were Irish, they were not British. And it comes down to language as well and terminology. Ireland was never part of Britain. There were people who identified and still identify as British who lived in Ireland, but it was part of the United Kingdom of Great Britain and terminology. Ireland was never part of Britain. There were people who identified and still identify
是的，这是一个非常精彩的问题。关于这一时期的反事实设想，例如爱丁堡大学的杰克逊教授（一位杰出的历史学家）曾对其进行过研究，他探讨了如果当时批准了地方自治会发生什么。这是一个非常棘手的问题。我能说的是，爱尔兰社会中一直存在一种从未接受联合王国概念的力量。而在中间，有相当大一部分人口，他们是爱尔兰人，而不是英国人。这也归结为语言和术语问题。爱尔兰从来都不是不列颠的一部分。有些生活在爱尔兰的人曾经并将继续认同自己是英国人，但它是大不列颠及
as British who lived in Ireland but it was part of the United Kingdom of Great Britain and Ireland. That geographic boundary had to matter
爱尔兰联合王国的一部分。这种地理边界至关重要，
and maybe in time things would have been dissolved to the point where it wouldn't matter anymore but there was no evidence in history that that would be the case.
也许随着时间的推移，事情会逐渐淡化到不再重要的地步，但历史上没有任何证据表明会是这样。
But it does go ahead and Fogel-McGarrion brilliant book on the rising. Yeah, it's a it's a fantastic book he he describes the proclamation with which we began this series as a stunningly ambitious act of imagination and the amazing thing about it is as you've been saying that this stunningly ambitious act of imagination creates a reality that maps onto the act of imagination in the long run. Because what happens in due course is the war of independence, the civil war, the establishment of the free state, independent state of Ireland exists now, kind of does follow from this to a
但它确实进行了下去。福格尔-麦加里昂关于起义的精彩著作——是的，这是一本非常棒的书——他将我们本系列节目开头的那个宣言描述为一场极其雄心勃勃的想象力行为。而奇妙的是，正如你一直在说的，这个极其雄心勃勃的想象力行为创造了一个在长期来看与该想象力相契合的现实。因为随之而来的是独立战争、内战、自由邦的建立，如今独立的爱尔兰共和国的存在，在某种程度上确实延续了这一点，不是吗？
degree, doesn't it? And you look at some of the people who are here, who came back, and we didn't mention the people who came from England or Scotland to fight in this rebellion, one of whom was Michael Collins, who came back having worked in the post office in London for a while. And they learned the lessons, because there had been a dispute in the volunteers before this one, whether they should be going into a hedge campaign, as in it would be guerrilla warfare. But they learned the lessons. They never set up in the city again. They go for guerrilla warfare and it is the rebels who are from here they build from this and they build out into success where the idea of anything less than ultimate independence will not be acceptable but that is another story is that
你可以看看这里的一些人，那些回来的人，我们还没有提到那些从英格兰或苏格兰来到这里参加这场叛乱的人，其中就包括迈克尔·科林斯，他曾在伦敦邮局工作过一段时间后回来了。他们吸取了教训，因为在此之前志愿者内部曾有过争论，讨论他们是否应该进行游击战式的伏击行动。但他们吸取了教训。他们再也没有在城市里建立据点。他们转向了游击战，正是这些本地的叛乱分子在此基础上不断发展，并取得了成功，在这里，任何低于最终独立的想法都是不可接受的——但那是另一个故事了，那就是——
we will have to we will clearly have to return to dublin at some future point to do the rest of the story. The War of Independence, the Civil War, Ireland in the 1920s and so on. I know we're also going to do a series about the Troubles at some point, so more Irish history to come. And I hope Joyce. Tom's desperate to do Joyce because Tom wants everybody to know, and this is really
我们显然在未来的某个时候必须回到都柏林来讲述故事的其余部分。独立战争、内战、20世纪20年代的爱尔兰等等。我知道我们迟早也会制作一个关于北爱尔兰冲突的系列节目，所以未来还会有更多爱尔兰历史。我希望乔伊斯……汤姆非常渴望讲乔伊斯的故事，因为汤姆想让每个人都知道——这正是本系列节目的意义所在。这就是我们希望人们能够记住的故事，对吧，汤姆？你曾经在都柏林赢得过一件T恤和一个詹姆斯·乔伊斯主题的酒吧知识问答比赛冠军。是的，但我不希望这成为我们结束节目的音符，多米尼克。好吧，不会的，因为我们必须向保罗·劳斯表达巨大的谢意，他表现得非常出色。我们对你提出了很高的要求，保罗，因为基本上你的任务是包揽所有的爱尔兰历史。所以非常感谢你，不仅因为你在本集节目中的精彩表现，
what this series has been about. This is the story we want people to take away, isn't it Tom? That you once won a t-shirt and a james joyce themed pub quiz pub crawl quiz competition in dublin yes but i don't i don't want that to be the note on which we end dominic no well it won't be because we should say a massive thank you to paul rouse who has performed manfully we've asked an awful lot of you paul because basically your brief was to do all Irish history. So thank you so much, not just for your fantastic performance in the episode,
还因为你在都柏林对我们的热情款待。而且我们昨晚还办了一场现场秀，对吧，汤姆？所以谢谢所有到场的人，谢谢我们所有的爱尔兰听众。还要谢谢安格斯·莱夫蒂，他为我们提供了这个房间，可以俯瞰曾经的萨克维尔街、现在的奥康奈尔街。
but also for your tremendous hospitality here in Dublin. And we also did a live show, didn't we, last night, Tom? So thank you to everybody who came, to all our Irish listeners. And also thank you to Angus Lefty, who has provided this room, looking out over what was Sackville Street, is now O'Connell Street.
我们现在就在这里。我的意思是，还有什么地方比GPO（邮政总局）本身更适合录制这个系列节目呢？所以谢谢你，保罗。也谢谢大家的收听。再见。拜拜。再见。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。
And here we are. I mean, what better place to have recorded this series than in the GPO itself. So thank you, Paul. And thank you to everybody for listening. And goodbye. Bye-bye. Goodbye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History.
想要收听更多额外节目、提前获取内容、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。网址是 restishistorypod.com。本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。
For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. That's restishistorypod.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。